your majesty
vice prime minister ribeira
dear friends of the spanish hydrogen
association and hydrogen europe
distinguished guests
for years science has been telling us
that we must end our reliance on fossil
fuels to save our planet
now the kremlin's attack on ukraine has
given us yet another reason
and that is to secure our energy
independence
the transition cannot wait
scaling up alternative sources and
carriers is more urgent than ever
and spain can be a great source of
inspiration for the rest of europe
for at least three reasons
first spain is a european and global
leader for renewable energy
second
spain has built through the years
a rich and diversified network of energy
suppliers
and third
spain has become a very attractive
country for green hydrogen 2.
in the first three months of this year
20
of all new clean hydrogen projects
announced in the world
were in spain
and that's impressive
spain is home to large-scale projects
like luck hydrogen
where the co-location of solar and
electrolyzers
is cutting the cost of power by
two-thirds
and gas pipelines are being converted to
carry green hydrogen to france and
beyond
a shift is happening in spain and across
europe
from small scale subsidized hydrogen
to mass scale competitive hydrogen
our task is now to accelerate
some will tell you
that hydrogen is for the future
i disagree
europe's hydrogen economy is being built
today
for instance as we speak
countries on the north sea are
announcing that they will increase their
offshore wind production at massive
scale
and use part of it for clean hydrogen
clean hydrogen already proves its value
to decarbonize our economy and even
better
it is beginning to be competitive also
from an economic point of view
but of course we are not there yet
if we are to meet our climate goals
and end our dependence on russian fossil
fuels
we must ramp up our ambition
and this is why the european commission
in its new plan
we power eu has doubled the eu hydrogen
targets for 2030
to 10 million tons of renewable hydrogen
produced annually in the european union
by 2030
and another 10 million tons in annual
imports
we must complete the construction of the
european hydrogen economy
so that we offer your industry the
conditions to move faster
today i would like to focus on four
actions that will get us there
first
injecting public investment to leverage
even more private investment
second
cooperating closely with industry to
advance projects and innovation
third giving the industry the
predictability it needs
and finally
building a truly global market for
hydrogen
with the current rise in gas prices
green hydrogen can already be cheaper
than gray hydrogen
our target is
to bring its cost well below 1.8 euros
per kilo by 2030
and this goal is within reach
the more we invest the quicker we'll get
there
this is my first point
we have to scale up clean hydrogen
production expand its applications and
create a virtuous cycle where demand and
supply feed each other and bring the
prices down
our recovery plan next generation eu is
worth 750 billion euros over four years
and one third of it
will finance the gold set in the
european green deal
to ensure sufficient renewable
electricity
to produce the renewable hydrogen
in figures
9.3 billion euros of recovery funds
are going straight into hydrogen
projects
at the same time the commission is
assessing state aid
for hydrogen projects as a priority
our
so-called important projects of common
european interest in short ipcei
on hydrogen
shall be approved by the summer
this will kick-start large
industry-driven investments which are
worth well over 50 billion euros
and thus hydrogen is a perfect example
of what public private partnership can
achieve and that's my second point
it is the concept that inspires and
drives our european clean hydrogen
alliance
because our entire hydrogen transition
is about cooperation to de-risk
investment
build a massive project pipeline and
push the innovation frontier
our recently launched new clean hydrogen
partnership
will add 1 billion euros
to research and innovation
matched by another 1 billion from
industry
it's a new step to bring innovative
technologies
from the laboratory
to the factory floor and ultimately to
european businesses and consumers
and this brings me to my third point
because for this corporation to
intensify and become a virtuous cycle
industry and private investors need
predictability
the european union is giving you targets
for 2030.
the technology and public investment is
getting on stream
and now come the rules of the game
i am glad to announce that the
commission has presented today
as part of repower eu
the hydrogen accelerator
with this
all regulatory measures announced in the
european hydrogen strategy
have now been completed
this means that we can start with the
actual construction of an integrated gas
and hydrogen infrastructure
including storage and port
infrastructure
and with the development of a global
european hydrogen facility
we will transform and connect our
regional hydrogen ecosystems
into the world's leading hydrogen market
and thus my final point is about the
global hydrogen market
what has begun in europe
in our labs
in our regions
and in member states
will now turn into a competitive global
market
big harbours in europe
the americas
the middle east
africa and australia
already creating new shipping corridors
for clean hydrogen
europe's global investment strategy we
call it global gateway
is there to support green hydrogen
projects around the world
we have partner countries that have an
abundance of renewable energy
sun and wind and water power
europe wants to buy green hydrogen from
them
and we are ready to invest in their
projects to get them running
because energy diversity
is also energy security
we want a clean and lucrative hydrogen
market
led by europe and its partners
to sooner rather than later
replace the global market for dirty
fossil fuels
this is how we can build a european and
global hydrogen economy
the targets and rules are in place
the investment
and tech is there
and together we are making it happen
because green hydrogen is not just a
huge commercial and development
opportunity
green hydrogen is energy security for
europe
and it can provide climate security for
the global community
i wish you a successful conference
thank you very much